Come to the second part
on atheism. I do agree that atheism is
spreading.
And I remember when I'd gone to Saudi
Arabia in 2015 when I got the King
Faisal Award,
Jamiyatul Imam called me to give a talk,
and they chose the topic give a talk on
does God exist?
Jamiyatul Imam,
according to me, one of the best
Islamic universities in the world.
I sent my son to study there. I
considered better than Medina
University. Let's not debate.
I sent him there, AND THEY ASKED me to
give a talk on does God exist?
Where I feel the situation of Tahir, and
then I come to know, you know, in the in
the Arab world, there are books on
atheism which are translated and sold
more than the English world.
Atheism is spreading
even in the Muslim world.
So, how do you reply this by the
prophetic method?
There are many methods of how to deal
with atheism.
Let me tell you one method that is
commonly used
by the Westerners.
But I've never used it
as a day. I know about it. I never used
it. This is the first time I'll be
speaking about it for a reason.
The contingency argument.
It was the argument that was first
started in philosophy by Plato, by
Aristotle,
hundreds of years
in BC. Then it was propounded by
by Ibn Sina
in the 11th century, and then then then
Al-Ghazali in the 12th century, then we
have people
like Thomas Winfrey in the
13th century, and the present
by Godfrey Leibniz, what we know today
of the contingency argument, that there
should be a necessary being. I know
about it. I never used it in any of my
dawah. The I should know. But I don't
speak about it here and there.
I believe in the prophetic method,
number one.
Because I'll come to it why I don't
speak about it, and about
the
the infinite regress, which is used by
some of the Western dais.
But I don't use it because if I was on
the opposite part and if I have to be a
debater against that,
I would kill the argument very easily.
If you're going to prove about a
necessary being,
contingency theory means that if it's a
contingent, there has to be a necessary
being.
It cannot be, you know, who created
this?
This bottle, someone created. Who
created that? It cannot go for infinite.
There has to be a necessary being. And
we agree that logically. All this
argument was spoken by Ghazali and all,
but these are all metaphysical
and philosophical, not hardcore.
Therefore, we should know about it as a
die, but I don't use it as a trump card.
We should know it. We should be prepared
for it because if I'm on the opposite,
okay, there's a necessary being. The
necessary being is a devil. What are you
going to do?
So, my argument is to prove Allah, not
necessary being. If the opponent says
the necessary being is the devil,
argument is lost. Or if he says, "Okay,
there is not one necessary being, there
are 10 necessary beings." That means
they have to agree there are 10 gods.
What are you going to do? So, I as a
die, I use the prophetic method which
was asked by me.
The best method is the Quran. You should
have knowledge
of the contingency argument, of infinite
regress. You should have as a die. It
can be used as supplementary, but not as
the core argument.
And that's the reason today there are so
many atheists. That doesn't prove
hardcore way. It talks about
metaphysical, philosophical argument,
not hardcore. The only way we can prove
hardcore, and I gave in the talk when I
gave in Jamatul Imam,
and I repeated the talk in Korea, it's
available for more than 3 hours.
Does God exist? Number one I'll do,
I will congratulate the atheist.
People wonder why Zakir congratulate an
atheist.
The reason I congratulate him is because
he's thinking.
Most of the human beings, they are
Christian because father is a Christian,
is a Hindu because father is a Hindu.
Most of the Muslims are Muslim because
father is a Muslim. He's thinking.
Okay, my father believes in God who can
die, so I don't believe in God. Oh, my
father believes in a God
who abducts someone's life and he takes
the help of another God. So, he says
there's no God. I congratulate him
because he's saying the first part of
the Islamic Shahada la ilaha, there is
no God.
HE MY HALF MY JOB IS DONE.
LA ILAHA, THERE IS NO GOD. Only thing
you have to do is the second part,
illallah, but Allah and Muhammad
Rasulullah, which is easy. HALF MY JOB
IS DONE. When I'm speaking to a
Christian, first I have to prove to him
that Jesus is not God, peace be upon
him. Then I have to prove about Allah.
If I'm speaking to a Hindu, I have to
prove his God.
Yeah, half my job is done.
So, first thing I do to atheist is
congratulate him.
I agree with you, there's no God
except Allah.
Then, rather than asking many people
a fallacy, who created this mic? Who and
who created that? Who created that? Ah.
God created.
The atheist will ask, who created God?
You're stuck.
This is a philosophy used by certain of
the duats which I say don't do it.
Don't dig your own grave.
At that time you should know the
contingency argument
that there has to be a a necessary
being. But why you're putting
your foot in the mouth?
What I do is I ask him a simple question
that if an equipment is brought in front
of you who no one in the world has seen.
I'm I'm talking to an atheist.
If an equipment is brought in front of
you
who no one in the world has seen,
who will be the first person who will be
able to tell you
the mechanism of that equipment.
Can you guess what the answer the
atheist can give?
Who is the first person who can tell you
the mechanism of an object which no one
knows about?
Who is the person?
Maker.
Maker,
creator, inventor, producer.
Don't grapple with the words. He will
tell you the creator or maker, inventor,
producer. Agree with him. Just keep that
word at the back of your mind. I agree
with you. The first person is the
creator or the inventor or the maker.
And the second person will be the
creator or somebody else. Done.
Ask him, "How did our universe come into
existence?"
He will tell you, "You know, there was a
primary nebula and then there was a
secondary separation. There was a big
bang which gave rise to galaxies, the
sun, the moon, and the earth we live
in."
When did you come to know about this? It
was in 1973 when a couple of scientists
got
the award. They got the Nobel Prize.
And they called it the Big Bang. Ah,
1973.
About 53 years. Yeah, 53 years back.
I tell him, "You know, my Quran 1,400
years ago
same thing is mentioned in the Quran in
Surah Anbiya, chapter 21, verse number
30. A walam yaral alladhina kafaru anna
samawati wal ardha kanata ratqan
fafataqnahuma. Do not the unbelievers
see that the heavens and the earth were
joined together and we clove them
asunder?
No, you came to know 50 to 53 years
back. My Quran says 1,400 years back.
Who could have mentioned it? Maybe it's
a fluke. Okay, no doubt. Yes, possible.
Fluke.
Okay, now my Quran says,
"What is the shape of the earth?"
He says, "Spherical."
"How did you come to know?"
"When someone traveled around the earth
in the 16th century."
"How many years back?"
"400 years back."
"Quran says
in Surah Nazi'at, chapter 79, verse
number 30, "Wal ardha ba'da zalika daha
and thereafter we have made the earth
egg-shaped." And there are various other
verses in the Quran that proving the
earth is spherical.
Rather it speaks it is geospherical,
shape of the egg of an ostrich. Daha.
And you know the egg of an ostrich is
not like a round ball, it is flattened
from the pole. The exact shape of the
earth. Who could have mentioned this?
Look, don't argue. Possible.
I'll ask him, "The light of the moon, is
it its own light or reflected light?"
He will say, "It's not its own light,
reflected light." When did you come to
know? He'll tell yesterday. Yesterday in
science means 50 years back, 100 years
back, 200 years back. But the Quran says
in Surah Furqan, chapter 25, verse
number 61, that Allah has placed the
constellation in the skies
and
placed siraj, sun, having a light of its
own, the shams, and
qamar, the moon, having nur, a reflected
light. The Quran says the light of the
sun its own light described as siraj,
wahaj, or diya, meaning own light, lamp,
torch.
And the moonlight is described as nur or
munir, a borrowed light or reflected
light. So, what you came to know
yesterday in science, 100 years back,
200 years back, 300 years back, my Quran
says the moonlight is reflected light.
400 years back, who could have said
that? So, he will give a pause and "Oh,
maybe your prophet was very genius."
Don't argue. Continue.
We know
the planets revolve. Does the sun
rotate? He said, "Yes."
When you came to know? "When I was in
school,
I read in 1982
that the sun revolves but does not
rotate."
Now science tells us that the sun
rotates and takes about 25 days to
complete one rotation.
What I did not know in school,
Allah says in the Quran in Surah Anbiya,
chapter 21, verse number 33,
"Walladhi khalaqal layla wan nahara."
It's Allah who has created the night and
the day. Wa It's Allah who has created
the night and the day, the sun and the
moon. The sun and the moon. Each
one traveling in an orbit with its own
motion. It has been described as the
motion of a moving body. If on the
floor, it will mean it is walking. If in
the water, it will [laughter] mean
swimming. For a celestial body, it is
rotating. What I did not know in school
now in your school it is mentioned
because now the books have been revised.
So, what I did not know 50 years back,
Allah says in the Quran,
the sun is rotating. Who could have
mentioned that? There'll be a big pause.
Don't wait for the answer. Continue.
Quran is not a book of science, s c i e
n c e. It's a book of signs, s i g n s,
ayat. There are more than 6,000 ayat,
signs in the Quran, out of which more
than a thousand speak about science.
After every I just give you example of
three for you again in my talk on Quran
modern science. I gave it last year
in the palace
police convention.
After every sign, who could have
mentioned this? And I can go on and on.
The universe is expanding in Surat
Dhariyat, chapter 51, verse 47. It talks
about physics, atoms, zarra. The zarra
is not the smallest thing, which we did
not know until recently.
In Surah Yunus, chapter 10, verse 61, it
talks about biology that from every
water, every living creature is made
from water. That is chapter number 21,
verse number 30. We have created every
living thing from water.
Will you not then believe?
Today science tells us every animal is
made from water.
Surah Nur, chapter 24, verse 45. Every
human being is made from water. Surah
Furqan, chapter 25, verse 54. And it
talks about zoology, animals live in
communities.
Surah An'am, chapter 6, verse 38. It
talks about in the honey the That the
bees, they have a special methodology
of communication in Surah Nahl, chapter
16, verse number 68, 69, that in the
belly of the bees, there is a drink of
varying colors
in which there is healing for humankind.
That honey has healing powers in Surah
Nahl, chapter 16, verse 69. Who could
have mentioned this?
We did not know that honey had healing
powers.
Hadith says that.
Talk about zoology, talk about
embryology, alaqah, talk about Go on and
on.
Who could have mentioned this?
The answer which the atheist give first,
the creator,
the producer, the maker, the inventor.
This creator, this producer, this
inventor, we Muslims call as Allah.
With hardcore science,
we are proving
logically the existence of Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala.
There are various ways.
I will ask the atheist,
you say there's no God.
What is the definition of God?
It's a logical point. When I say there
is no God, I should know the definition
of God. If I say,
"This is not a pen."
I may not know what is this, but I
should know the definition of pen.
If I don't know the definition of pen, I
cannot say this is not a pen.
So, if you are telling
there is no God,
can you define me what is God?
So, the moment the atheist says there's
no God, what is "Oh, you know, God who
can die." Even I don't believe in such a
God. "You know, God who requires to eat
food." Even I don't believe in such a
God.
So, what is the definition of God?
If you deny something, so in argument,
you should use logic, very important.
Yes, you read the book
of
Dawkins,
Bertrand Bertrand Russell. You know, he
says that if someone says that the
kettle is revolving around the earth. It
is his job to prove. Yes?
But for you to say kettle doesn't
revolve, you should know the definition
of kettle.
I agree with you. It's not your job to
prove
that God exists.
But it's your JOB TO DEFINE WHAT is God
if you say God doesn't exist. And then
when you whatever definition you give
we say the right definition is Surah
Ikhlas.
Chapter number 112, verse number 1 to
12.
1 to 4. Qul huwallahu ahad. Says Allah
one and only. Allahhus Samad. Allah the
absolutely eternal. Lam yalid wa lam
yulad. He begets not nor is he begotten.
Wa lam yakul lahu kufuwan ahad. There's
nothing like him. So this is the
four-line definition given about Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in the glorious
Quran. IF ANY INDIVIDUAL AGREES with
this four line of definition, whoever
you assume to be God, we Muslims have
got no objection accepting that entity
to be God.
So this
and if you hear my debate with us sorry,
my talk on does God exist, it has
various different ways of how to prove
the existence of God. And wallahi, you
only with the Quran
can you prove the existence of Allah.
Hardcore existence. All the other
philosophical debates that we have can
be argued upon. So I tell the Muslims
use the Quran.
There is no better way than the Quran to
prove the existence of Allah. If you use
any other book, you will fail.
This is the prophetic method.
Use the prophetic method. How he when
when Rasulullah sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in Masjid an-Nabawi
when the Nasaras, the Christian asked
him, "Who is Allah?" The prophet was
shocked. Not that he didn't know.
How can you define Allah? You will It
will take us
The wahy is revealed. Qul huwallahu
ahad. Says Allah one and only. Allahhus
Samad. Allah the absolutely eternal. Lam
yalid wa lam yulad. He begets not nor is
he begotten. Wa lam yakul lahu kufuwan
ahad. And there's nothing like him.